you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chest coms
tactics trainer and going to do another
group of three puzzles and simply share
my thoughts along the way well this one
is very simplified and we are in check
um okay my first thought is just take
tonight pawn takes knight king d7 king
f6 king e8 black will hold the draw the
next movie they're picking up the pawn
or ending up in stalemate so it must be
a king both and so we're to go with the
king must be here or hmm not necessarily
huh yeah it might actually be king to g5
that would be pretty cool my thinking
with King e6 is that the knight could
play to g6 and I don't see how we're
pushing through King e6 King g6
if we go to f5 again they could always
return to e7 King e6 Knight g6 f7 we're
just we're not going to be able to stop
the pawn or excuse me we're not gonna be
able to promote the pawn without the
knight being able to sacrifice
the night we'll be able to stop us from
queening King e6 Knight g6 f7
we're not even threatening anything if
later that can goes to f6 then that goes
here and he's he'll have squares to go
to hmm I think it is actually King to g5
with the sneaky idea where if the black
King approaches with King d6 we simply
bypass the night with f7 and then we're
promoting next king g5 if the knight
goes here we just push if the knight
goes anywhere we just push and we're
gonna be getting a queen huh yeah I
think it must be King g5 that's a pretty
sneaky one I missing anything I don't
think so it's got to be here Oh actually
one way to reason it is I mean once
we're past this point where we know on
takes Knight will lead to a draw if we
go anywhere but g5 if the knight can
make use of g6 he'll be able to stop the
pawn any other square yeah all these
other squares that he goes to won't be
enough to stop the advance f7 f8
yeah it must be king g5 and we just go
right by here and promote
okay that was a very simplified puzzle
to start I'm to just dive into the
analysis taking would result in this
position here where whites on move
here's stalemate and any other move
allows King takes pawn okay interesting
first puzzle let's try another hmm we
might end up having to do a fourth cuz
I've had this one before all right yeah
if you've been following this series
you'll know that I've had this puzzle
before where we're supposed to take give
this check and then come here and it
should be solved okay
let's maybe go for four puzzles than
this one let's try another okay
team white okay
this pawn is pinned we could take the
knight is there something better though
I think there is also we take stock of
the material we're down a minor piece so
far Queen takes Knight there's Queen
takes Bishop and we're in check I'm
thinking it's more rook takes Bishop
yeah rook takes Bishop within the idea
of taking on d6 with check and even
taking the knight possibly with check
let's uh be a little bit more accurate
here rook takes Bishop quite the forcing
first move rook takes rook Queen takes
d6 Knight blocks would just take and
it's me if king c8 we pick up the rook
with check so probably not there so I
believe the King has to go to eight rook
takes Bishop rook takes rook Queen d6
kingi eight what would we do there we'd
give me
with Queenie six and that seems
convincing enough mmm am I missing
anything I don't think so
just kind of skimming here to see what
other candidate move there would be on
move one I don't really see it it must
be rough takes Bishop rook takes Queen
here and I guess the computer would go
to c8 and we scooped up the rook wits
check and yeah I don't know if it would
even take it any further
maybe maybe let me let me calculate that
a little bit further rook takes Bishop
rook takes rook Queen takes here King c8
we pick up the rook with check the King
has to go to c7 where would we go from
there I guess we could scoop up this
rook in the corner and allow Queen takes
bishop here but maybe there's something
better and there would be actually yes
the Queen would return to d6 to give
check and after king c8 the queen goes
to d8 and that's mate okay I'm glad I
went through that because I think it is
going to test us with that very line
rook takes Bishop rook takes rook Queen
takes pawn King e8 is King e6 King c8 we
take the rook with check the King goes
to c7 we play back to d6 King c8 and
then Queen d8 is game over let's do it
it's very forcing and this will turn out
to be mate oh okay well puzzle solved
from here but just to show the night
went oh this is how the puzzle started
Queen takes if it continued King here
Queen here's mate and King here we would
grab the rook returned to d6 and then go
into d8 for me all right
let's try
one last one team black hmm let's see
well this rook is protected by the Queen
the bishop is pinned our Knight is under
fire how we to materialize it's balanced
sort of yeah now it is balanced it's a
very dangerous pawn I'm assuming we need
to
do something really strong here I don't
know that we could just go for the win
of I don't know a bishop or something
this Knight is under fire maybe even the
pond could push and look to Queen where
is why you vulnerable
well currently this bishop is powerless
uh-huh so that actually just pointing
that out I think is giving me the answer
to this one hmm
we could attack the bishop with our
queen queen a6 and queen to e2 and how
are they so is white stopping Queen
takes Bishop mate mm-hmm that must be it
taking advantage the pinned piece my
only concern is there are two ways to
attack the bishop on ease to an e2 and
a6 which one would be better it must be
a six because if we play - e - there's
rook takes rook which then forces us to
take on a one with our Queen and then
white could play King to g2 and get out
of the pin the trick here must be to
play to a 6 so that unrep takes rook we
can recapture with the rook and there's
really no stopping Queen takes bishop
next nope no good way to stop that move
next and this should just run right into
mate taking advantage of the pin hmm I
don't think I'm missing anything that's
quite forceful who cares about our night
when we have Queen takes bishop mate
they could move their pawn but still
when we take here king h2 queen h1 is
game over you know I think that should
do it and I don't think I'm missing
anything the big thing was recognizing
the pin taking advantage of this
attacking the pinned piece further and
working out the difference between these
two squares e2 and 80
e to an a6 I think we got it that is
correct and we take here and puzzle
solved not quite okay I don't think
there's too much consider here I think
we just play King here we don't even
have to take this rook if we take the
rook we're allowing Queen takes Knight
King g8 Queen d8 check and then maybe
even the bishop coming here I think
simplest is to scoot our king up
there's no good Queen check and we don't
allow the bishop to move to give check
so we just get out of harm's way
yeah it's solved from there okay not a
bad group of three that extra one again
if you've been following this series you
may recall that one maybe I should have
given a little bit more time in case you
didn't see that video where I covered
that puzzle but anyhow as usual feel
free to leave any feedback to this video
in the comments section below
let me know how you did with these 3/4
and as usual I hope you got something
out of it that's all for now take care
bye
you